- Wassup?
- We the legends of
Chamberlain Heights.
- These is our top lines
for skipping Valentine's.
(flatulence)
- Hey Doug, will you be my date?
- Hell na.
Why I need a beezy to
take me out to eat,
buy me yeezys, and wash the
skeet stains off my drawers?
That's what I got moms for.
Aah!
- Hey Grover, will you go
to dinner with me tonight?
- I see talent in
your thirst palate,
but Lebron's gonna boo-boo
all over Minnesota tonight,
and I can't miss the goat.
(smack)
Aah!
- Hey Jamal, will
you be my Valentine?
- Uh, sorry boo,
but my momma just found
out she got the HIV,
so uh, yeah, me and my
dads, we gotta go uh,
hunt down magic and
uh, seek revenge.
(smack)
Ooh!
- Is you ready for
our date tonight?
- Sorry boo, you gots to get
in line to get with this nine.
(smack)
Aah!
- Hi cutie, you wanna
take me out tonight?
- Damn, boo, what
you eat for lunch?
You got some certified,
flagra-four halitosis.
- What's up, Jamal?
You wanna be my Valentine?
- This nigga.
(smack)
Aah!
♪ Legends
(hip hop beat)
♪ What